welcome back to our Channel today we
have got something exciting and highly
informative in store for you we're
diping deep into the world of devops
devops has emerged as a pivotal approach
to software development and deployment
as we set our sides on 2024 it's
imperative to understand the trajectory
of devop jobs so in this video we will
have a look at the top 10 devops jobs
you should be keeping an eye on in 2024
so whether you are an aspiring devops
Pro or just curious about the hottest
career in Tech this video is a mustat
let's get started but before we begin
let me ask you a quick question so which
of the following is a key principle of
devops first soil teams and departments
option b is manual and time consuming
deployments option C is continuous
integration and continuous delivery and
option D is is limited collaboration and
communication now you can pause this
video and answer in the comment section
below so now let's just start with the
first topic that is the first job site
reliability engineer SRE a site
reliability engineer is responsible for
making sure that the applications and
systems are always available reliable
and able to handle increased demand they
achieve this by using their expertise in
automation monitoring and Incident
Management sres work to ensure that
everything runs smoothly and efficiently
they also play crucial role in defining
service level objectives slos and
service level indicators slis which are
used to measure and improve the quality
of service in simpler terms sres are
like the Guardians of a company systems
making sure that they stay up and
running smoothly even during the
challenging times to become site
reliability engineer you should have the
skills like coding and pyth Pyon Java go
Etc cicd pipeline development and
implementation distributed computing and
Cloud platform management other than
that software performance and
reliability monitoring and testing are
also necessary the average salary of a
site reliability engineer is
$142,000 per year in the United States
the average additional cash compensation
for site reliability engineer in the
United States is
$26,000 now talking about the companies
companies like VMware Google reckle Vio
Juniper Network Etc are hiring for sres
all right so this was about the site
reliability engineer now the next devop
job is release manager so a release
manager plays a crucial role in the
software development process they
oversee the release of software
applications into production ensuring a
smooth and efficient process they
collaborate closely with development and
operation teams to coordinate task and
ensure that all necessary steps are
taken before releasing the software this
includes conducting thorough testing
coordinating with stakeholders and
addressing any issues that may arise
their goal is to ensure that the release
software meets the required quality
standards and fulfills the needs of end
users to become a release manager you
need to have Proficiency in using
release management tools such as jira
gitlab or Microsoft Azure devops
deployment automation Incident
Management Version Control Systems Etc
now talking about the salary of a
release manager the average salary for a
release manager is
$140,000 in the United States the
average additional cash compensation for
a release manager in United States is
$25,000 now talking about companies
companies like Simons work freaks orle
General Motors and arise virtual
Solutions are actively hiring for
release managers all right so this was
about the release manager now coming to
the next job which is devops engineer so
a devops engineer is crucial role in
software development process they focus
on implementing and managing the
infrastructure Automation and deployment
pipelines devops Engineers work closely
with development and operation teams to
ensure a smooth and efficient release
process they are responsible for tasks
such as configuring and maintaining
Version Control Systems setting up man
managing cic tools implementing
configuration management scripting and
automation to become a devops engineer
you must have skills like Version
Control Systems like git subversion
continuous integration and continuous
deployment tools like genkins Travis
Azure devops configuration management
scripting and automation infrastructure
as code Cloud platforms like AWS Azure
Google cloud containerization and
orchestration all right now coming to
the salary the average salary of a
devops engineer is $38,000 in us the
average additional cash is $24,000 in us
talking about companies companies hiring
for devops engineers are IBM forac Cisco
Systems Amazon Google sap and Galaxy
Technologies there are a lot more than
companies for all these professions but
we are just covering some of the
companies that are actively hiring for
these roles so if you aspire to become a
devops engineer simply learns
professional certificate program in
cloud computing and devops is your idea
launch pad in partnership with E and ICT
Academy IIT guti this program equips you
with the skills needed to excel in cloud
computing and devops learn to deploy I
repeat learn to deploy robust Microsoft
Azure and AWS applications through a
blend of live virtual classes Hands-On
Labs self-paced videos and collaborative
peer interactions don't miss this
opportunity to master the art of cloud
and devops enroll today and pave your
way to become a cloud expert all right
next up we have is Dev SE Ops engineer
Yes you heard it right a Dev SEC Ops
engineer is a professional who combines
development security and operation
expertise to ensure secure software
development and deployment they
integrate security practices into devops
workflow focusing on identifying and
addressing vulnerabilities early in the
development process only devops
Engineers work closely with development
and operation teams to implement
security controls perform security
testing and automate security process a
Dev secop Engineers should possess a
strong understanding of software
development security principles and
operations they should have expertise in
security tools and Technologies
knowledge of secure coding practices and
the ability to automate security
processes the average salary of a devops
engineer is
$146,000 the average additional cash
compensation for devop engineer in the
United States is
$26,000 all right now talking about the
company's hiring so company's hiring for
Dev Ops engineer is Boing sap new light
Technologies saic US Department of
Veterans Affairs Etc all right moving on
to the next one that is automation
engineer automation Engineers develop
and maintain automated testing
Frameworks and tools to streamline
software development they create scripts
and workflows to automate repetitive
tasks like testing and deployment by
automating these processes they improve
efficiency reduce errors and speed up
software delivery automation Engineers
collaborate with development and
operation teams to identify areas for
Automation and ensure reliable and
scalable automated processes automation
engineer processes the skills like
programming test automation tools
example selenium scripting bash cicd
Version Control testing Concepts problem
solving collaborations and agile methods
now talking about the salary of an
automation engineer the average salary
of an automation Engineers is
$100,000 the average additional cash
compensation for an automation engineer
in the United States is
$10,000 now talking about the company's
hiring so the company's hiring for
automation engineer is Intel Corporation
workday fiser Flex Simons Champion
technology services Etc all right so
this was about automation engineer next
on the list is cloud engineer so a cloud
engineer is responsible for Designing
implementing and managing cloud-based
infrastructure and solutions they work
with platforms like AWS Azure or Google
Cloud to ensure scalability reliability
and security Cloud Engineers deploy and
manage virtual servers storage and
networking sources and they optimize
Cloud environments for perform
performance and cost efficiency they
also collaborate with development teams
to enable seamless integration and
deployment of applications in the cloud
must have skills for cloud Engineers
includes Cloud platforms virtualization
networking security scripting
infrastructure as code I terraform cloud
formation all right now the average
salary of cloud engineer is
$114,000 the average additional cash
compensation for a cloud engineer is
$9,000 talking about the companies
hiring for cloud engineer Cisco recel
IBM rack space technology Deo and AWS
are the companies that are hiring for
cloud Engineers all right so this was
about Cloud Engineers that is another
top devop job now moving on to the next
top devop jobs so the next one is devops
architect so a devops architect is a
rule that focuses on designing and
implementing the overall devops strategy
and infrastructure within an
organization they work closely with
development teams operation teams and
other teams to create seamless and
efficient software delivery pipeline
devops Architects are responsible for
selecting and integrating the right
tools Technologies and processes to
enable continuous integration continuous
delivery and automation a devops
architect should have expertise in
Technologies such as Cloud platforms AWS
Azure gcp containerization tools Docker
kubernetes infrastructure automation
cic tools scripting languages and
monitoring and logging tools all right
now talking about the salary of a devops
architect the average salary for a
devops architect includes
$172,000 that is a whole lot of money
the additional cash compensation for
devops architect in the United States is
$33,000 all right talking about the
company's hiring company's hiring for
devops architect includes Maven wear
grid dynamic mix optimal Technologies in
forces cognizant Etc all right so this
was about the devops architect following
this we have is cic CD engineer so a
cicd engineer focuses on automating the
software development process from code
integration to deployment they design
and Implement continuous integration and
continuous deployment pipelines enabling
faster and more Reliable Software
releases by automating task like
building testing and deploying code they
help teams deliver software more
frequently and with fewer errors
improving overall efficiency and
productivity a cicd engineer must be
proficient in Version Control System git
git build tools genkins containerization
platforms like Dockers and have
knowledge of AWS and Azure all right now
the average salary for cicd engineer is
$19,000 the average additional cash
compensation for cic engineer in the
United States is like $133,000 now the
company's hiring for cicd engineers
include Google Amazon Salesforce IBM Etc
all right so this was the another devops
jobs that are in demand that is cicd
engineer coming to the next job that is
IAC engineer an infrastructure as code
that is IAC engineer is responsible for
managing and automating infrastructure
using Code based tools and Frameworks
they use languages like terraform or
Cloud for to Define and provision
infrastructure resources such as servers
networks and Storage by treating
infrastructure as code is engus enable
consistent skillable and repeatable
deployments reducing manual errors and
improving efficiency in managing
infrastructure skills of an is engineer
typically includes Proficiency in
infrastructure automation tools like
terraform or cloud formation knowledge
of scripting languages such as python or
Powershell and understanding of cloud
platforms like AWS or azure so the
average salary of an Isa engineer is
$117,000 the average additional cash
compensation is
$9,000 companies hiring for Isa
Engineers are hups specialty systems
prom monary interf Financial networks
Wind River Etc all right so this was
about is engineer now at last we have is
devops trainer so this is the 10th one
so a devops trainer is an individual who
specializes in teaching and educating
others about devops principles practices
and tools they provide training sessions
workshops and courses to help
individuals and teams understand and
Implement devops methodologies
effectively devops trainers possesses
in-depth knowledge of various devop
tools and Technologies and have the
ability to communicate complex Concepts
in a clear and understandable manner a
devop trainer should have strong
technical skills in areas such as cloud
computing automation tools genkins Etc
containerization tools like docker
kubernetes infrastructure has coded cicd
pipelines and monitoring and logging
tools the average salary of dup's
trainer is
$17,000 the average additional cash
compensation of a devops trainer is
$7,000 talking about the companies for
devops trainer so companies hiring for
DeVos streamers include Planet DDS
Oracle Blue Sky Technology Solutions
anxiety Center Etc all right so there
you have it folks the top 10 devops jobs
to wash out for in 2024
these careers are at the Forefront of
innovation and they are changing the
tech landscape as we know it which one
excites you the most let us know in the
comment section below and don't forget
to like And subscribe for the tech
insights with that we have come to the
end of this video If you like this video
please give it a thumbs up I hope it
really help you all thanks for watching
stay safe and keep learning staying
ahead in your career requires continuous
learning and upskilling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here